We're going to start the count
Good Luck
I Can't believe that in half an hour, I will be a part of the the Domus gaming
Dynasty Empire Dominion. We prefer Dominion. Yeah
I honestly can't wait to be a part of your family
There's just one more thing and then you are officially part of the family so
At midnight you have to play game why it's just something we do when someone new joins the family a game
what game I
Didn't think I'm really gonna play that well, the rules are simple
You can hide anywhere
We then trying to find you. So there's no way for me to win right and stay hidden. Don't wanna know. Thank you. Good luck
The hell is this how what was this thing? I know you're in here. Oh
Geez so you shot the maid that she look like she's wearing a giant white wedding dress Emily. Oh
Shit, I had to play along today. I can get you about Fame
They think that the kind for sunrise or something very bad will happen to the family
If we don't find her and perform the ritual we're all dead
Found her
And
Today's video is called
Getting to know your crossbow
Why don't you just use mine, that's really Thomas I just saw her ready
To just another sacrifice
Is a fucking time yes, I didn't see in order to get married
You